we got another one uh this is from end
wokeness Rashida Talib who's also in the
Hamas caucus uh she has this is great A
representative Rashida Talib is flying a
Palestinian flag and an lgbtq pride flag
outside of her office who wants to tell
her yeah you know the thing is with the
they them crowd if you go to Gaza first
they behead they and then they behead
them that's how it works over there but
again this shows the radicalism of the
Democrat Party these ideologies have
nothing to do with each other right do
you think for so think about it they put
the Palestinian cause at the height of
their thing right like it's just it's
the Jews are bad somehow the Jews had
nothing to do with Israel and the
history of the Bible and thousands of
years of archaeological reality and
historical reality and everything else
but the Jews are really bad and they're
oppressing these people and then somehow
they've combined that with the
lgbtq2 spirit element op Fiasco right
she knows like go lady take grab a
couple Les and go to Gaza and see what
happens see what happens but she will
not but the hypocrisy of these people uh
never
[Music]
end